[Musique]
alors là j'ai l'impression d'être en
ligue des champions la musique je passe
après aider le ca berkane c'est un peu
le real madrid la conférence et moi on
va dire considérez moi comme l'olympique
de marseille alors non mais attendez
attendez attendez attendez ça veut dire
que les résultats sont pas forcément au
rendez vous mais le coeur y est là
aujourd'hui je vais être avec vous et
donc moi je l'avais le dgi et mohamed
je suis médecin et je suis aussi
chroniqueur sur ces 8 et à la radio sur
europe 1 et aujourd'hui on va parler des
réseaux sociaux
d'abord en faire un petit est tout
simple dans la salle est ce que vous
pouvez me dire qu' ici en levant les
bras à soi instagram soit facebook soit
site twitter soit snapshot lever la main
ok je pense que ceux qui n'ont pas levé
la main sont des mythos mais c'est pas
grave alors petit quizz tout simple quel
est le point commun entre zidane
george clooney et bernard tapie
george clooney n'est pas marseillais
donc ça paraît pas évident mais aucun
des trois n'a twitter zidane il a un
pseudo compte qu'il n'alimente plus ils
ont peut-être d'autres réseaux mais ils
n'ont pas eu besoin de ça pour réussir
et avoir une notoriété deuxième test
quel est le point commun entre bill
gates steve jobs et mark zuckerberg
c'est pas l'argent je lis tout de suite
c'est pas non plus leur nationalité ce
serait trop simple on et conférences
tedx quand même donc on va monter un peu
niveau
alors j'ai entendu en fait ils ont
développé n'en sont pas supporters de
l'olympique de marseille j'ai entendu ça
maintenant ils ont développé des outils
ou contribuer à développer des outils
qu'ils ont restreint leurs propres
enfants
bill gates a dit qu'il ne donnerait pas
de smartphone à ses enfants avant l'âge
de 14 ans et même lorsqu'ils l'ont ils
le restreint steve jobs a dit je ne
donnerai pas de tablette ni l'ipad que
j'aimerais me construis mes propres
enfants ayant des dirigeants un ancien
dirigeant de facebook a dit qu'ils
n'utiliseraient pas c'est le réseau
social pour ses enfants
alors avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais en ce moment dans les médias et un
climat un peu particulier un peu tendu
on entend beaucoup de phrases à droite à
gauche qui sont un peu blessantes
et qui parfois sont vraiment énervante
et ça c'est lié au fait que désormais
sur les plateaux télé on a ce qu'on
appelle des éditorialistes alors
éditorialiste à par extraordinaire on
dit c'est un polémiste ça donne une
fonction incroyable mais a été un
éditorialiste sait rien d'autre
quelqu'un qui est là que parfois
journaliste est là pour donner son
opinion
c'est pas forcément un expert est
généralement ce n'est pas un expert est
le but du jeu c'est qu'il donne son avis
et donc il n'est absolument pas ni
neutre ni objectifs ce qui va donc dire
qu'il faut se méfier de leurs paroles
évidemment et des éditorialistes qui
disent des choses intéressantes mais je
vous donne un exemple dernièrement sur
une chaîne d'information en continu vous
avez un éditorialiste qui habituellement
parle du fromage
il est critique gastronomique respect
moi je serais incapable de nommer tous
les fromages sur ce plateau
mais c'est son job sauf que le mec qui
parle du fromage en permanence
normalement on lui a demandé son avis
sur l'effondrement d'un pont à toulouse
c'est pour vous dire à quel point on est
désormais dans une société du spectacle
une société où les experts ne sont plus
présents ce qui veut dire que
éditorialistes n'est pas synonyme
d'experts un expert c'est quelqu'un qui
est reconnu par ses pairs comme étant un
expert ça veut dire qu'ils ne se
prononcent pas lui-même experts et c'est
quelqu'un qui publie dans des journaux
scientifiques avec un comité de lecture
des tests des conclusions qui n'ont pas
été réfutée par ce comité
alors pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que
désormais dès lors qu'on entend des
choses un peu choquant un peu blessant
ça peut concerner des minorités
certaines communautés
on s'en indigner on sent attaquée moi le
premier et du coup qu'est ce que je fais
bah quand c'est comme ça on publie en
général sur twitter on se plaint on dit
regardez ce qu'il a dit ça absolument
insupportable c'est horrible
regardez ces s'indigne il faudrait qu'il
soit censuré ce n'est pas digne et on a
raison
sauf qu'en faisant ça on fait une grave
erreur l'erreur qu'on commet c'est que 1
vous diffusez l'information souvent ces
éditorialistes disent leur petite phrase
sur des chaînes d'information comme très
peu d'audience et donc vous allez
propager l'information malgré vous
deuxième effet en propre au genre
d'information ça entraîne ce qu'on
appelle le buzz
on va parler de lui et du coup on va le
réinviter sur d'autres chaînes pour
reparler et donc sans vous en rendre
compte vous donner une nouvelle tribune
à ces personnes donc vous indigner sur
twitter
contre-productif au contraire vous
mettez en lumière la personne qui a dit
des choses blessantes et elle sera
réinviter elle fera de l'audience et
vous serez d'autant plus énervé mettez
ça de côté qui a déjà ici dans cette
salle en faire un deuxième test changé
d'opinion fermement il était pourri
tenus contre après avoir lu un poste un
tweet sur twitter ou facebook qui a
réussi ou à changer l'opinion quelqu'un
après avoir publié quelque chose je
crois vous êtes le seul monsieur vous ne
changerez pas les gens sur les réseaux
sociaux
les gens sont sur les réseaux pour
donner leurs opinions parfois déverser
leurs haines et il ne faut pas leur
portée de crédit on passe en moyenne
1h30 par jour en france sur les réseaux
sociaux viennent dire 1h30 c'est pas
énorme parce que finalement ces quelques
minutes par ci quelques minutes par là
sauf qu'à la fin de l'année
à la fin du mois ça fait plus de vingt
jours que vous avez perdu sur votre
téléphone
la dernière chose qu'on fait en se
couchant et moi le premier c'est que je
regarde mon téléphone
la première chose que je fais en me
levant c'est que je regarde mon
téléphone est ce qu'on ne se rend pas
compte c'est la charge mentale qu'on
s'inflige en regardant des informations
de façon perpétuelle
vous n'avez pas besoin de savoir tout ce
qui se passe partout dans le monde 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 parce que
finalement ça parasites votre cerveau et
ça contribue au fait d'être malheureux
vous allez me dire mais parfois les
réseaux sociaux ont du bon parfois on
fait des choses extraordinaires ont fait
avancer certaines causes et là je vous
raconter une histoire personnelle j'ai
mon dernier enfant donc j'ai trois
enfants il est né grand prématuré grands
prématurés donc il a été hospitalisé il
est né pendant la période de canicule
et pendant cette période de canicule à
l'hôpital la climatisation ne marchait
pas donc j'avais un bébé prématuré il
faisait 40 degrés dehors et dans les
chambres c'était insoutenable
d'autant plus que les bébés ne savent
pas à réguler leur température dont il
ya un danger
en plus de ça les soignants visant des
conditions atroces c'est absolument
insupportable et du coup on leur dit
mais réparer la clim il ya forcément
quelqu'un qui sait faire ça on dit non
écoutés dans cet hôpital c'est comme ça
en hiver il fait froid
les parents mettent des manteaux et en
été il fait chaud et c'est comme ça
depuis des années on peut rien y faire
il est impossible de régler cette
clinique je me dis non mais moi je sais
pas réparer des clim jeu sert pas à
grand chose mais j'ai un tout compte
twitter donc je vais balancer un tweet
et l'âge interpelle un mec c'est un
cadre de l'ap-hp des hôpitaux de paris
et je lui dis tranquillement
pendant que tu es dans ton bureau
climatisé sache que la climatisation en
soins intensifs de l'hôpital trousseau
en néonatologie ne marche pas c'est
dangereux pour les nouveau nés est
insupportable pour les soignants bon
j'ai lâché mon tweet je dis bon voila
j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait je me suis
plaint comme bon parisien on est
tranquille résultat dès le lendemain un
ventilateur apparaît dans la chambre de
mon fils je me dis ah bon ils ont
investi et ce qui est sournois c'est que
ce ventilateur
ils ont pris du bureau des soignants
pour le mettre dans la chambre de mon
enfant est en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que le tweet est remonté à un haut
niveau et ils ont pris peur et ont dit
on va réparer la clim mais ce qui est
cynique dans l'histoire c'est qu'ils ont
dit on va réparer la clean que de la
chambre de votre enfant
rendez vous contre la violence à côté de
ça on a deux bébés mais pour l'instant
c'est votre chantier prioritaire il ya
une urgence sur votre chambre
évidemment imaginer l'insultent pour les
soignants qui nous faut dire ce qui est
faux maximum dans les hôpitaux sont
souvent débordés pas payer correctement
et au delà il ya un mec qui twitte un
guignol personne ne connaissait à
l'hôpital j'ai pas du tout une notoriété
importante qui fait un pauvre tweets ils
vont réparer la clim c'est incroyable
évidemment qui se sont plaints éclat
climat est réparé dans l'intégralité du
service et puis finalement dans tout le
bâtiment car en réanimation en étage au
dessus c'est exactement la même chose à
la maternité pareil donc je me dis c'est
bien twitter c'est formidable sauf que
du coup j'ai commencé à regarder et je
me suis rendu compte que des parents qui
font ce genre de tweets en a partout
elle a plein mais leur réponse n'est pas
entendue donc en fait c'est juste
l'image un peu folle de notre société
qui réagit au fait divers à la
médiatisation et cet outil qui semble
être un outil d'information pas
finalement ne sert pas à grand chose
là on va passer à tout autre chose c'est
une scène de la vie quotidienne je pas
si vous avez remarqué
désormais quand on est au restaurant on
a tous un réflexe un peu bizarre on dit
plus bon appétit ça c'était avant
c'est désuet on prend en photo son plat
bizarre quand même quand on mange une
salade ou un vieux hamburger on prend en
photo pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça je
sais pas et désormais les genres observé
jean restaurant peut être vous même vous
avez ce genre d'attitude
on ne parle plus on reste sur le scotch
et sur nos téléphones et ses outils qui
sont censés nous connecter les uns les
autres
finalement nous éloigne on ne parle plus
on sait même plus qu'on sait plus quoi
se dire parce que comme on s'ennuie on
tue l'ennui sur le téléphone au lieu
d'essayer de tuer l'ennui
on essaie en discuter
en tête de file instagram instagram
c'est le réseau social à mon sens ce qui
multiplie le narcissisme parce que sur
instagram vous publier uniquement de
belles photos moi j'ai jamais vu
personne publié découvert sur instagram
d une lettre d'huissier ou une facture
allant c'est évidemment à relancer
évidemment qu'on publie que des choses
positives positive et en publiant ces
choses positives sans vous en rendre
compte
chez les autres même quand votre vie est
misérable même quand vous êtes triste
même quand c'est compliqué eh bien vous
créer de l'envié chez les autres et une
forme de jalousie et donc les gens vont
se dire ce mec il a une chance
incroyable alors que cinq minutes avant
vous étiez malheureux dix minutes après
vous l'être mais comme vous avez publié
cette photo vous avez travestit la
réalité et c'est d'autant plus pervers
parce que à force de publier des moments
de bonheur
c'est humain de dire que tout va bien
les gens ne cherchent plus à savoir
comment est ce que vous allez réellement
plus personne ne vous demandera au fait
comment tu vas évidemment que tu vas
bien ta part de publier des photos de
tes vacances des photos de ton plat des
photos de la ville que tu as visité donc
en fait vous êtes en train de vous
éloigner en faisant ça alors certains
diront bon mois instagram je sais le
gérer je suis pas malheureux de ma vie
les réseaux sociaux je gère mes ce que
vous savez que les réseaux sociaux à
travers l'utilisation du téléphone ou un
impact sur votre santé un impact réel et
surtout que vous connaissez déjà mais
qu'on préfère ignorer le premier c'est
évidemment les troubles du sommeil
on sait tous que utiliser son téléphone
avant de dormir au travers des lumières
bleues perturbe votre horloge biologique
qui a l'impression d'être en plein jour
alors qu il est 23h et donc vous dormez
moins bien le fait de moins bien dormir
d'avoir des troubles du sommeil
évidemment que c'est un impact sur votre
santé on s'est rendu compte que ça a
entraîné un déclin cognitif
on a fait des irm à des gens qui avaient
trouvé des troubles du sommeil on s'est
rendu compte qu'ils avaient des dépôts
amyloïdes des plaques on appelle ça
c'est neil semblables à ceux qui avaient
la maladie d'alzheimer bon avoir un
trouble du sommeil et pas dormir
s'entraîne aussi des maladies
cardiovasculaires on sait qu'on a plus
de cancers notamment au travers des gens
qui travaillent de nuit mais ça aussi ça
paraît très loin utiliser son téléphone
avant de dormir
ça fait grossir alors ça on ne sait pas
donc c'est pas beaucoup et des études
qui le prouvent
ça fait grossir même un peu plus les
femmes que les hommes deux mécanismes le
premier c'est les lumières bleues qui
perturberaient les sensation de satiété
au niveau du cerveau donc un message
chimique est deuxième
ça concerne tout le monde sait que quand
on est sur son téléphone et qu'on est en
train de manger le cerveau est incapable
de décoder les deux actes ensemble je
mange et je regarde un profil instagram
je mange et je twitte et le cerveau
considère que l'activité intellectuelle
est prioritaire et vous avaler sans vous
en rendre compte
une quantité bien plus importante et
vous prenez du poids alors encore une
fois vous allez me dire le summer baudis
est pas pour tout de suite
on a le temps on nomma dessin me fait
froid on cache tout chauds et doudounes
pas de problème bien un deuxième un
troisième est fait qu'on connaît pas
en asie il ya une épidémie de myopie 9
asiatiques qui font des études sur dix
sont myopes et parmi eux deux sur dix
ont une myopie tel qu'il risque de
devenir aveugle et cette épidémie myopie
elle en train de se transposer petit à
petit chez nous en france
alors évidemment que la myopie n'est pas
contagieuse mais dites vous que quand
vous êtes derrière un écran au travail
parce qu'on a de plus en plus un travail
sédentaire derrière un ordinateur vous
rentrez vous êtes dans les transports
vous êtes de nouveau sur votre
ordinateur
et puis une fois chez vous vous êtes
encore dr des écrans ce qui fait que
votre oeil devient feignant vous
accommoder que sur de très courtes
distances et il n'a plus l'habitude de
regarder au loin ce qui contribue au
fait d'avoir la myopie alors il ya deux
façons de lutter contre ça la première
ça concerne les enfants évidemment pas
de tablette pour les enfants mais
surtout si vous en donner une
mettez les dehors le fait pour un enfant
de gambader de regarder au loin
l'oiseau qui se trouvent dans l'arbre
permet à son oeil d'accommoder plus loin
et de ne plus être feignant ça un
message de prévention
parallèlement à ça on sait que les
enfants en 30 ans ont perdu 25% leurs
capacités cardiovasculaires ils courent
moins bien être sont moins endurants et
puis pour les adultes
il ya une règle toute simple que vous
appliquez c'est un médecin indien qui a
découvert ça c'est pas de moi c'est la
règle des 3 20 toutes les 20 minutes
pendant 20 secondes vous regardez à 20
pieds
c'est à peu près six mètres et ça
permettra à votre oeil d'être un peu
moins fainéant
même si l'idéal évidemment c'est limiter
l'application lisez de l'accès au réseau
mais ça je pense qu'on n'est pas encore
prêts autre fait c'est que quand vous
avez une vidéo souvent on a des vidéos
un peu où on s'indigne encore une fois
choquant j'aimerais vous rappeler c'est
pareil dans la vie que vous voyez ce qui
se passe à un instant t
vous ne savez pas ce qui s'est passé
avant ni après vous avez une version
très tronqué très partiel soit d'une
citation soit d'une vidéo dans
c'est exactement la même chose et je les
ai pris conscience avec un visite que
j'ai fait à domicile puisque je suis
médecin je vois un monsieur de 95 ans le
pauvre est tombé par terre il ne peut
plus se relever il faut l'hospitaliser
il a accompagné de sa femme qui à 90 ans
qui marche difficilement et à leur fille
est présente elle à environ 60 ans et
donc je leur explique qu'il va falloir
commander une ambulance pour faire
hospitaliser ce monsieur est là ce
moment là la fille dit à sa mère qui à
90 ans maman mais les chaussettes mais
lui les chaussettes bon j'observe la
scène un peu loin et donc je vois la
maman s'exécuter marché et c'est lui
mettre les chaussettes avec du mal elle
a une coordination un peu hasardeuse
elle a du mal à se baisser a du mal à
lui enfilé elle en difficulté moi j'ai
envie de péter les plombs le dire mais
c'est quoi ça mettez lui les chaussettes
madame donc à ce moment là pour éviter
de créer une situation conflictuelle
jeudi à la maman madame voulez-vous de
l'aide et la safim stoppe net et me dit
non laissez-la bon on va pas proposer un
octogone mais quand même c'est un peu
donc je comprends pas je suis très
brusque et jeux en plus on projette sur
ses parents ses grands-parents
je me dis non mais je comprends pas
madame et là ils m'expliquent quelque
chose elle me dit maman la maladie
d'alzheimer et lorsqu'elle fait ça ça
stimule son activité cérébrale et ça lui
permet de garder un peu d'autonomie
tout ça pour vous dire qu'il ne faut pas
juger les gens sur un instant t
quand ils font quelque chose de bizarre
demandez leur pourquoi tu fais ça quel
est le but qu'est ce qui s'est passé et
vous verrez que bien souvent les
situations vont se résoudre elle-même
enfin il ya quelque chose qui on va
essayer de dégager un message positif
quand même plus que vous allez me dire
bon ça rend dépressif ça rend aveugle
ont bien gros c'est un peu l'angoissent
latex jimmy plombe l'ambiance et ben il
ya quelque chose qui peut changer votre
vie ça tient en cinq lettres c'est le
mot merci
vous allez dire il est sympa lui merci
je le dis quand j'ai acheté ma baguette
jeudi quand quelqu'un me tient la porte
mais je raconte une histoire c'est un
enfant de 6 ans qui m'a fait comprendre
comment être heureux de nouveaux géants
visite et je vois dans un appartement
une famille sont 5 2 dans trois enfants
deux adultes
ils vivent dans à peu près 15 16 mètres
carrés l'appartement
je vous passe la décoration elle est
minimaliste on voit que c'est des gens
qui ont très peu de moyens
l'aîné à 6 ans la petite que je dois
soigner à neuf mois je fais la
consultation rien de gravissime et j'ai
expliqué la maman ce qui se passe hélas
non là il ya un enfant de 6 ans qui
s'appelle adam je n'oublierai jamais me
dit écoute tiens je te donne ce petit
cadeau
c'est un enfant qui est rien chez lui je
le voyais très peu de jouer pas de vivre
une vie difficile
il a décidé de me donner un des rares
joueurs qui l'avaient est donc ce qu'il
a fait sept enfants
c'est au delà la générosité c'est
quelque chose qui a un pouvoir
extraordinaire et que lui il a compris à
6 ans et que moi j'ai mis plus de trente
ans avant de comprendre ce sentiment il
a un un pouvoir magique sur votre
cerveau il peut vraiment changer votre
vie s'appelle la gratitude la gratitude
c'est le fait d'être reconnaissants on
trouve la gratitude énormément dans les
religions la religion catholique le dit
l'apôtre paul disait qu'il fallait être
reconnaissant on trouve ça évidemment
dans la religion juive et chez les
bouddhistes aussi on trouve la même
chose qu'il faut être reconnaissant la
gratitude mais on trouve ça aussi chez
les musulmans avec la formule que tout
le monde connaît el hamdoullah il
grâce à dieu le fait d'être
reconnaissant un impact sur le cerveau
mais évidemment et des gens qui ne sont
pas croyants et à ce moment là on peut
se demander comment être reconnaissants
et donc c'est les choses de la vie
quotidienne tout simple vous arrivez à
voir votre métro à l'heure où deux bus
soyez reconnaissants
vous avez passé un moment agréable avec
votre enfant un jeu de société vous avez
ri soyez reconnaissants
vous allez partager un moment en famille
soyez reconnaissants et dit le dit le
verbaliser le même si on le sait qu'on a
de la chance parfois on oublie mais il
faut le verbaliser et ça c'est un
pouvoir extraordinaire sur votre cerveau
parce que les études le montrent ces
scientifiques que ça réduit votre niveau
d'angoise ça augmente vos performances
vous êtes vous dormez mieux vous
diminuez vos risques d'insomnie et de
dépression et enfin les études montrent
que vous pouvez gagner jusqu'à sept ans
d'espérance de vie
soyez reconnaissants les uns envers les
autres de la même façon que c'est un
honneur d'être parmi vous je suis
vraiment reconnaissant d'être là donc je
vous exprime toute ma gratitude
[Applaudissements]